[Music]  blow me down because it helped to raise  or she like he likes his marmalade it I  have a feeling he'll go far  dear Aunt Lucy wife in London has been  better than ever  I really feel at home if you had one was  tonight what would it be  I'd like to get my Aunt Lucy a birthday  present all knowed pop-up book of London  the only problem is it's rather  expensive where on earth did you find  this mr. Gruber's antique shop cheerio  we're rich again afternoon chaps I may  look like a hardened criminal  but I really am meanness you're gonna  clear your name  you're gonna need our help having just  made such sweet friends I mean  what a clever little bit come back with  a box  Paddington looks for the good in all of  us and somehow he finds it if we kind  and polite the world will be right  Paddington too  [Music]  oh that's not good rated PG  [Music]